having had a brief look at where runs
out I think you probably passed me to be
honest what have we done so far
I've gone ahead and I've found my
derivative please look at your working
right now and look at what you called
the derivative if you didn't call a dar
DX especially because the question even
told you hey it's called dar DX please
change that right now because the theme
of your being the model and you're
working with it has a specific name when
you have other things flying around the
question and you'll have a question that
involves area and volume and height and
all kinds of other things right you need
to be able to distinguish between them
if you don't call things what they are
you're going to just land yourself in a
lot of trouble I've got my derivative
sum of wanted how did I get to this
point I factorize that the common factor
of two right here so that meant turns my
one-eighth into 1/4 and then I've said
oh look there may be a turning point at
x equals five there's definitely a
stationary point but I haven't
determined its nature yet that's why I
went to the second derivative and
hopefully you found the same thing okay
so my actual answer to Part C what is
the x value that makes a a minimum is
this except think back to the first half
of this lesson this something that I've
left out think carefully
we made a headline about it as well hmm
there are constraints on the situation
right there are constraints you can't
have for example like a wire of negative
length and you can't have a wire of
infinite length either because how much
why do you have to play with this 10
meters exactly right so therefore and
this is so sneaky it's why it's kind of
like I just blew right past it to see if
how many of you would notice there is a
constraint baked into this that no one
said anything about but it's there in
the question right number one we said
you can't have a negative length of wire
so that means that X has to be positive
greater than equal to zero but in
addition to that you don't just have
like whatever amount that you want to
play with you've got this as a maximum
so that means X has to be less than or
equal to 10 which of course we could
include including one single inequality
you could say that that's 0 is less than
X less than 10 and I've included my
boundaries okay now just as a very very
minor point it's
having a very small discussion about
whether we should include these
boundaries or not I've written them with
boundaries does anyone think we should
exclude them like should we should we
write this instead include there's a
finite length so it's like oh I can get
up to ten it's not like an asymptote or
anything right back so strain you're
saying like I have no wire over here and
I just have one square over here well
what do you think so okay this is really
interesting right so what I'm gonna do
what I'm gonna say is um practically
speaking practically speaking it doesn't
matter how much in this particular
question right but just there's a very
very small thing just go back right to
the starter question right back to start
this is one of those times where you've
got to interpret language here and think
about what does that mean mathematically
your translate how many how many squares
being formed two squares two squares if
I used all ten meters on this first
square here what would you have left to
make this so you'd only have one square
right so actually probably to make two
squares you can't include these right
but at the same time I want to
understand like well do the endpoints
give me something meaningful so you've
actually got to substitute in something
so it's the zero or the ten which I
actually do want to quickly test with
you right now let's just go ahead and
see what happens if if I did include
these endpoints right hopefully you can
see at zero or ten you're gonna get the
same result right why you're gonna get
the same result if you had zero or ten
why is that because you either have this
guy's a square or and nothing here for
you have this guy's a square and nothing
set so you have the same square either
way right so here I'm going to test my
endpoints or in this case is just an
endpoint right so I'm going to test x
equals 10 I've got my model way down
over yeah so help me out if x equals 10
what's a going to be equal to 20 25
you've already evaluated 25 over 4 this
is an area so it's in square meters okay
I actually haven't done this already
maybe you're ahead of me I haven't
tested what happens at x equals 5 I know
it's a minimum turning point but I don't
know what it's equal to
has anyone substituted X equals 5 into
the original function already if not
please do that now and I'll hold on
because I don't have a calculator on
hand 25 over 8 25 over 8 which is half
it's half of this area over here so this
one is clearly smaller we had to test it
just to be sure I mean we expected it
was a minimum turning point but as we've
shown just because the minimum turning
point doesn't mean it's the minimum
there could be some sneaky endpoint
which shows you it's not the case all
right so finally are we are we done
what's it say and find the least
possible value of the combined areas
that's it right there on the bell as if
on cue